[Music]
everyone this is Steve on trip with
Collider and I'm at the collider studio
at the Kia Telluride supper suite in
Sundance with the folks behind Serge
first of all congrats on being part of
the festival thank you so much yeah yeah
nice feeling so I have a million
questions for the two of you but I have
to start with the most generic and I'm
sorry but everyone watching this will
not have seen the movie yet so could you
sort of talk a little bit about help
what the movie is about yeah well I
should caveat that with it's quite quite
impressive but I've spent look out of
five or six years with this film and I
still can't succinctly sum up what it's
about like a lot you not like not a
consistent and concise one no but it's
it I mean it's kind of about a man
played by Ben called Joseph living this
very kind of Numb existence which is
kind of devoid of feeling and meaning
and human relationships really and kind
of circumstances come together and
there's a kind of cracking point and he
begins dismantling that life and and
beginning to live on impulse and putting
kind of feeling and instinct at the at
the crux of how he operates I mean that
sounds so abstract but in more tangible
kind of physical terms it takes him on
this kind of mad reckless journey
through London over the course of kind
of 48 hours where he begins you know all
these kind of transgressions from his
normal very linear boxed ways the
behavior start to happen and they start
with the small almost imperceptible
maybe and then they grow to the kind of
life-altering transgressions where
life's never going to be the same again
yeah that got better I have to listen I
work constantly and you're in that
fortunate place of I'm sure being able
to pick projects what was it about this
script that said I need to do this well
one of the things that was particularly
special about this project was that it's
something that kind of organically in a
way grew
between us because Anil and I had made a
short film that Anil wrote and directed
called beat about seven years ago
everything and after that then you'll
talk to me about an idea that at that
point was about a man who robbed a bank
and you were doing quite a lot of
research about people who robbed banks
kind of impulsively without having
thought his single thing about doing it
before which apparently is a phenomenon
that some of the very early stages of me
writing and kind of treatment even was
coming across this research about bank
robbers which was really interesting
because because it it kind of exploded
the kind of myths that you that you are
the preconceptions about bank robbers
you have from popular culture you know
I'm a big fan of bank robbery films but
but why wouldn't you be yeah it's a
great question but but so so this
research proves that firstly like 60 or
70 percent of bank robbers had never
committed a crime in the lives before so
they were kind of not career criminals
not you know hard guys not tough guys
and secondly they were kind of
completely and completely opposite of
the kind of alpha males that you're used
to from the films they were kind of
quite reticent and visible characters in
the world who more than trying to get
rich we're trying to kind of reinvent
themselves and it was a lot more about
masculinity and how its perceived and it
was kind of like real life mimicking
culture in a way how can i reinvent
myself and become a man so the the
earliest incarnations of this were about
kind of more about masculinity and and
bank robberies but the heart of it and
then they start and then both those
things took a little bit of a back scene
it became about a more Universal
exploration of what makes life
meaningful I suppose so so I I was
involved sort of not really but we you
sent me the script we talked ideas that
came up stirred ever ventually fed back
in so I was involved a whole time
and just very much excited by the by
what Anil wanted to explore really so
I've never been involved in a project
quite like that so that was wonderful so
basically from the infancy - yeah
finished yeah does that mean that you
were invited into the editing room or
was that mean that you were like oh no
you wasn't keeping me out but I wouldn't
have gone even if you do yeah exactly I
definitely wasn't keeping Ben out but I
mean I mean for one thing you just
incredibly busy and elsewhere and things
yeah I know the thing this is your
feature debut I believe yes so I'm
curious what was it like for you
stepping in the editing room for the
first time with all the footage were you
like scared out of your mind were you
super excited by it like maybe what what
didn't you know talk a little bit about
that how it all changed well in a kind
of experiential sense I wasn't so
terrified because I'd actually come even
though it's my first feature film I'd
come from though I've come from kind of
several TV projects so right before we
shot the film I was finishing a Netflix
series called top boy so so I was
definitely used to the experience of
having you know terabytes and terabytes
of of options and you know having to
start somewhere but what was slightly
more frightening about what was
definitely frightening about this
project was as you could probably tell
from their answer to question number one
it's really kind of strangely satiric
kind of themes that you're exploring and
I knew you know it's all very well
exploring these kind of like you know
philosophical questions and things but
if you if you can't route them in
reality and route them in a tangible
kind of narrative that kind of makes a
sense of all that then it's then there's
probably just going to be lost and kind
of haze of pretentious [ __ ] um so I
think that was what's scary about it you
know what I mean like can we get all
this madness that we shot and there was
a lot madness and you know can there be
100 minutes or whatever at the end of it
which tells a these you know
half-decent story and that you go with
do you know I mean that was one area
absolutely it wasn't so we basically you
were also probably looking for the tone
what exactly am i you know how was it
yet to be all finally put together
exactly yeah yeah tone was something I
actually had a fairly clear sense of in
my head but yeah I mean you never you
never [ __ ] know if it's gonna
actually like feel as good as it you
know your your minds I might feel but
yeah completely I'm a big fan of your
work and I'm thank you Steve and I'm
curious with a project like this and
also just in general through your career
how do you typically like to prepare for
a project and maybe using this as an
example as to the way you get into a
role find it really hard to talk about
and I think it's different from project
to project different projects seem to
require different things because we were
working in a because the film is about
somebody acting impulsively in a sense
it was just getting getting ready to do
that I mean instead of getting ready to
be really clear and really present and
and I wanted to be like kind of I
remember like thinking I want my body to
be able to move so I I didn't do I I
didn't do a workout or anything but I
was like I want my body to be I want to
be flexible and be because I know it
would be physically there would be
physical challenges but that was really
the only thing and then we talked a bit
and talked through the journey of the
character and but we didn't I think
because we'd been talking for so long
and sharing things for so long it just
by the time we started we would just
somehow quite ready yeah yeah I think so
and also because been touched upon there
because in many ways the story is about
a man switching from existing in the
analytical mind and that kind of noise
of that into a place where he's
operating on instinct kind of thing it
felt it felt in many in some ways wrong
to be super kind of painstaking and
considered and thorough about you know
rehearsing scenes to death and things
like that the freshness was kind of like
at the heart of the story in a way
because he was kind of having this kind
of rebirth where everything was feeling
he was feeling and experiencing
everything for the first time again in
many ways so that felt antithetical are
supposed to rehearsal to you know deep
rehearsal process so there was very kind
of there was it was more discussions and
then from the moment we went into it we
were rolling so there was something kind
alive about how we went about it I'm
fascinated by being on set and the way
directors like to work in the way actors
like to work some actors are spoken to
you think that they nail it on like the
first and second tape they have the most
energy and others they treat it like I
mean they could do 12 takes and they
feel like every take is you don't I mean
I'm curious how do you typically how
when do you think you're like most
comfortable does it change and for you
how many takes do you typically like to
do as a director and does it change
based on you know the talent or the
people you're working with I have no
idea about that I know that if it's um I
know that sometimes on the first take or
sometimes even the rehearsal you have
this extraordinary rush of feeling
because it's literally like it's
happening to you because it is happening
to you you're doing it for the first
time that gets harder to recreate once
you go into the second third fourth for
however many takes do but it doesn't
necessarily mean just because you were
feeling it that it was the best is why
I've come to learn over time so it's and
usually I could just keep going and
going and going because there's always
something more
you could try having said that I work
with people who - goes that's it
and it's something about that that's
very focusing and very
puts you right in the in that kind of a
live place which you need to be and
immediately Willie
yeah and been touched upon it slightly
and I did in the earlier question but we
were because I wanted to burn or Joseph
to be experiencing these things for the
first time we did certain things like
for instance there were some locations
that been wouldn't see until he who kind
of walked into them and there were
certain characters that he came across
on this journey of his that he wouldn't
meet until the first take because we'd
I'd keep them apart kind of things so it
was just about trying to inject as much
freshness and genuine discovery into
each take so that's that for that reason
it was a little different to other
projects because we would always shoot
immediately you know so and as been said
from that first take you got some
sometimes you'd get these moments of
genuine just realness and madness kind
of thing from that but but inevitably
you wouldn't nail everything then so I
mean I try not to do an insane number of
takes just because I'm aware that for
the most part the freshness starts the
diaphragm is and that must be a horrible
feeling I mean it's kind of no one likes
it so I try and keep it down but then
inevitably there are those moments where
you just you know it just takes ten I
have to ask you an individual question
or two because Cloud Atlas is a
masterpiece and I just want to bring it
up because I [ __ ] love that movie
so please not many people know that film
or go to see it or so it is some people
have first 10-15 minutes or a little
dense and once you it is and once you
watch it like twice and you can kind of
get it the movies a masterpiece I'm
really proud of that film and I've loved
I love um the directors the Wachowskis
are amazing could you maybe share what
you remember from making it or you know
well it was the thing was that it wasn't
just the wichowsky as it was done with
they worked with Tom tick for who I work
with on perfume and so that I don't
think had ever been done before when it
was divided in half you'd jump from one
it happens all the time in television
now but in film when directors they were
sharing out film basically and so that
was really I mean basically it was like
a kind of art film but with a budget of
a massive science fiction film or
something so it was kind of an enormous
experiment and one of the strands
storylines there was people speaking in
a unknown language isn't it yeah I mean
really kind of it was really not an easy
thing to sell so I feel very proud I had
a beautiful time working on you I know
it's a generic thing no no I totally um
and of course I have to ask you all of
us are obviously looking forward listen
I could ask you about Fargo and
everything else but I have to zero in on
bond because I'm so excited to see what
carrie has done it's me too
like I'm just curious what was it like
maybe collaborating and what what do you
think fans can look forward to well I
think it's Daniels last film as James
Bond so I think what they can look
forward to is a kind of summing up I
guess of all of the previous Bond films
that Daniels done there are strands from
all of the films in it kind of reaching
a conclusion
I like that in working with Carrie I
really enjoyed working with Carrie I
never know whether to call him carry or
carry and I never did I don't know it
was unset yeah I don't know what the
right answer is and I hope I didn't
screw this up I just said both things
depending on how I felt on the day oh
yeah no it was great and you know what
was amazing was the heat-treat he
treated it or was able to approach it it
felt to me as almost as if it were an
independent film you know and it was
quite improvisational and quite we
didn't do many takes it was it was very
light sometimes quite chaotic but I make
very excited to see how he's
constructed the final film yeah I am so
excited I got it on that note I want to
say cannot wait to see the film seeing
it Wednesday thank you so much I'm
coming in the studio
nice to see a huge thank you to Kia for
being an awesome sponsor and I hope you
guys have a fantastic festival aw I
really appreciate like thank you very
much during the film why are you so much